what would you say
to um to somebody who
encounters adversity in the workplace
they're young in their careers what's
what what were some things that guided
you outside of being
inserted into a situation where you
could really shine which is great
um but what what kind of guidance would
you give
people coming into the workplace
today which can be a hostile place
what i did i would not recommend to
people and that is
i didn't take very much risk
with my career and i think that young
people
should take a lot of risk i'm talking
like in your 20s
okay and i was just focused on this
place where i was and
one of my um personality traits which
probably is a double-edged sword is that
i can be sort of an optimizer
so i'm in a situation and i
optimize it but i don't i don't look for
other doors
right i'm just optimizing where i am
and i i think that i should have started
my own company
in 1992. 1993 at the latest
and i instead i just was one more day
one more day one more day until 2009
so many years later because you know
don't get comfortable yeah i i would i
would
encourage people to be more planners and
more
proactive than most people are
comfortable being
but when i started double eye and i had
some young people that joined up that
had been working with me prior
and there was one um and i said you know
i
wasn't paying people anything until i
realized was told that was against the
law
that california have to pay people some
minimum amount
um i we actually we were actually
weren't even really a company yet we
were just
a a swat team trying to work together
yeah
and there was one person who was 23 and
i said how can aren't you afraid
coming here i mean you're not making any
money and and she said to me jeffrey
i'm too young to have be afraid gosh
to go back there but when i was 23 i
think she was 23.
when i started three that's when i was i
wasn't any kind of a situation
optimized but i certainly wasn't afraid
i got into a car
and drove across the country without any
idea
of what was going to be there when i
crossed the california state line
[Music]
you